you had a very uh small fan how old
would you who proposed to you how old
was this
young lady yes uh a picture of it i
think i think she was five years old
five years old
look this is this is a fan who proposed
to you
uh and that's that's a very sweet moment
do you i mean
such a young kid do you get that kind of
fan reaction from
uh most five-year-olds yes yeah it kind
of ends there
yeah six they start looking at me
differently i don't know
you're no longer marriage mature not
really a six-year-old 85 you're a yeah
you're all set i have a four-year-old
daughter so
i'm anxious to see what next year what
uh what television star celebrity i'm
going to have to off
yeah has she expressed any interest yet
has she expressed interest in uh in in
just came home the other day and said
that she now
used to like brandon and now she loves
brandon
i don't know brandon
brandon's got to go yeah our kids go to
similar preschools and we both live in
austin and he called me one night he's
like
yeah austin yeah yeah
and he's like hey uh tom my
five-year-old ever talk about some
brandon guy
i know man like i i don't know what
you're talking about all right tell me
if uh tom talks about brandon i want his
number
yeah yeah he's five i don't think he has
a number kids a five-year-old yeah you
don't call them on the phone no you
don't and you don't really send them out
to put a hit on somebody